of things beyond differential privacy
she's thought about game theoretic
definitions of privacy cubes from an
information theoretic background and
looking forward to hearing about privacy
differentiated markets Thank You Aaron
slightly different talk from the
previous one but the spirit of
everything beyond right this is a work
with my really awesome graduate student
who's who's graduated and is doing
really cool work for FICO any of this so
I don't want to go here but I got a very
briefly mentioned that lets broadly as
you privacy means learning things
letting people infer things that you
didn't intend in your interactions with
them okay so obviously we all know the
stuff so I'm going to start quickly skip
through this but the only thing I want
to point out is a lot of us do work on
where we have a data set and perhaps we
can learn something
statistical from it and so either the
release from the data set while learning
the statistics is protected with some
notion of privacy or you want to publish
your data set and you have some notions
of privacy so this is something that
very familiar with
we're also somewhat familiar with cases
where a dealer collector collects data
in a very distributed manner and
provides some privacy guarantees by
saying well that's some noise we'll
learn statistics and so on now I'm gonna
talk about something very different I'm
gonna talk about is there even a notion
of privacy when consumers and retailers
interact with each other and then you
get a coupon for some pregnancy-related
product just because you're 16 and they
figured out you're pregnant even before
your parents figured it out so now how
do you even model these kinds of
problems and ask the question is there a
is there a way for retailers and and
consumers to have a notion of privacy
right so I I'm not going to actually
talk about how to quantify privacy I'm
going to ask the following question I
wrote a very broad problem but the
question I want to ask is if there were
such a measure of privacy could
retailers differentiate them okay so
everybody knows this right we're all
online and all
we online using a lot of products we use
a lot of products that are free and we
know what the consequences I mean
basically our data is their currency and
they get a lot out of it right but what
if and we love it we I think I like free
services who does it but the moment we
figure out oh yeah Google's doing all
this stuff and you go into Facebook and
it keeps putting these sponsored ads at
you they completely figure out
everything about you including your
browsing preferences or every website
you went to you at least you're creeped
out if not anything else
at least some people are creeped up keep
that in mind not everybody's creeped out
some people are kicked out right so so
Google said when they collect Eddie then
we can use something like rapport Apple
as some version of it works in some
context often I think at least I don't
know the entire details of their
mechanism sure there's an epsilon
associated with it but we don't know
what they do right so there is no notion
of choice in these contexts so the
question I want to ask is from a
somewhat game theoretic viewpoint can
there be a market for privacy
differentiate ourselves so there's a New
York Times article today about öppet
should Facebook be broken up I'm not
going to talk about whether there should
be a competitor of Facebook that offers
different products because in that
context there is a barrier to entry I'm
going to talk about a setting where
there are already two parties and they
offer slightly different services but
their services include a notion of
providing your privacy gafty okay so as
a running example and no offense since
this talk is being recorded to any of
these service companies just as a simple
toy model we'll talk about two service
providers will name one of them Google
it's just a cute little name and the
other one of them doctor goes because it
just seems like another interesting name
right and so when they offer their
services which could be for example web
browsing or such search engine they
could say we have a very high guarantee
on searches very good results
and they can also say but we use your
data only so much and that corresponds
to a certain privacy measure that right
so these two service providers have
their notions of search quality quality
of service and a privacy measure so the
question is how should the consumer pick
and the question is if say DuckDuckGo is
the company that provides you some
better privacy guarantees how many users
are going to actually take doctor
cursors so right off the bat if doctor
go does a much better is much better at
providing you very good searches and
provides a very good privacy guarantees
that's it there's no market here there's
no gaming it's all done so that's not
the situation we're gonna answer well
formalize this so here's your problem
there's a whole universe of consumers
they all they all have heterogeneous
choices and privacy and there are these
two service providers that pick
particular values out of these
heterogeneous choice right I don't know
how to do this without explicitly
parameterizing a few things and you may
not like it but I'm going to do it this
way so bear with me and this a bunch of
parameters starting from here and this
is important we're going to capture some
notion of consumers heterogeneity in
privacy choices okay I have to
explicitly model cost and revenue so I
can talk about profit okay so there's
these two notions and there is a notion
where you have to map things there's
there's privacy in this QoS how can I
compare them
so after map privacy to say some notion
of quality or QoS and that's where the
consumers valuation of privacy comes
okay none of us know how to compute
these things are hard to put numbers on
them but we'll go along in this
mathematical mark so obviously I'm not
the first one to do this have been
others we've looked at in the monopoly
case of a different shearing they've
looked at the non free markets like
price based competitions online and
they've also looked at a duopoly case
like the two service providers but but
very specific privacy guarantees so what
we're going to do is the free markets so
there's no price okay so the
differentiator is both the quality of
service
and the privacy preference that the
privacy guarantee that the service
product gives you and I'm gonna allow
consumers heterogeneity in privacy
choices to be just infinite okay so
immediately the one thing that comes
about it's a non non non cooperative
right if they cooperated so okay so if
you look at rapport rapport I think pics
epsilon equals one point one point oh
five I think so I don't know at least so
the point is there's a possibility of
picking different values right so one
may assume that each one of these
service providers fix a particular value
of epsilon epsilon could be over a very
large value I'm not assuming they're
doing differentiate private or any
privacy or anything like that but that's
an example so we're gonna assume that
the consumers also have heterogeneity in
choices and and the service providers
pick a particular point in that to
operate okay so there's a very classic
model in economics which is called a
Hotelling model or head telling also
happens to be a signal processing person
and it's this question if you had two
retailers if you have two to retailers
and they were offering the same product
but they had a choice of how to price it
and where to locate themselves how would
they do that
and there's a very classical model
they've been other models so we thought
we'll start here and and in our case
there's no pricing so as I already told
you we're going to differentiate by
keywords and privacy okay
so right off the bat and I've already
told you this there's a notion of
quantifiable QoS and quantifiable
privacy privacy risks okay so even if
there is no notion of a price there is a
cost for every service provider to do
these kinds of things so a service
provider can generate revenue from the
data that they collect unless there's
that notion of profit I think there's no
game here okay so the consumers
ultimately when a sir
Ferrara puts out that I'm going to pick
this kind of quality of service and
that's privacy risk consumers get to
choose between the two options so the
consumer is actually the person that
couples the two games the two parties
okay so okay now that we've done that so
we have two rational parties which means
they really want to maximize their
problem okay
so I've told you these now a little bit
of math we're gonna use the V's for QoS
or the news as you call them and the
Epsilon's because we all like epsilon
right epsilon for privacy risk okay and
I already told you this if dr. go gives
me a better privacy guarantees obviously
its quality of service better be less
otherwise there's no gaming so even more
simplifications some kinds of cost
models simple linear cost model in terms
of breaking up the cost none of this
makes any sense perhaps we're gonna
start something okay so I'm going to
zoom the cost depends on only these two
things QoS and privacy and I'm gonna
break it up into two parts
where I say that there's a cost for
either Google or doctor go to give you
some quality of service guarantees and
there's also cost to giving you privacy
guarantees you don't have to implement
it up or I have to come up with good
PageRank algorithms and so on and so
forth so there's a cost available right
and that revenue can also be broken up
into two parts there's a revenue from a
data stream that's you know I use your
private information I can get revenue
because I can have all these people
advertise to you directly and every time
they use my platform to do it I get
money on and they can also be an
independent kind of revenue which
somewhat hard to describe but you know
what I don't use your data but still
just by being there I have people coming
to my search using my search engine I
can get something now how do i model the
consumer retailer interaction this is
I'm going to model it okay so
people using the service no this is so
that'll come in that'll come in in a
minute this is sort of like per consumer
okay so so here's the Hotelling morgan
the hoteling model says obviously you
can space yourself anywhere in the
universe and i'm going to normalize the
distance between two providers to be on
the unit line sort of a linear simple
one-dimensional model so in our context
that will be DuckDuckGo sitting here and
google sitting here because they provide
two different privacy measures risks and
for our understanding the smaller the
epsilon they higher the privacy
guarantees of being okay all right
consumers can be anywhere on this range
and really there's really a big range
I'm just mapping that entire range to
zero so the end of this range is some
epsilon bar a consumer sitting somewhere
in between and a consumer gets to choose
in the classical Hotelling model the
consumer has a transportation cost to
each one of these retailers and it also
then picks the one that gives the best
price so the consumer maximizes utility
in that way and these folks have to
maximize their profit here and their
transportation cost is sort of
asymmetric here there's somewhat of an
asymmetry maybe I'm just like maybe I'm
a consumer so if I was sitting somewhere
here I would have a very strong I'd be
very very privacy aware for sitting
somewhere here really don't care about
privacy and if I'm somewhere in the
middle I'm worried a little bit about
price
right so if DuckDuckGo gives me a
privacy guarantee that's even lower than
mine
I actually gain by using doctor go in
terms of privacy I may not gain from the
the QoS so that the utility if a
consumer is going to come from both the
QoS and the privacy that's what I'm this
is where it is asymmetric and not
symmetric like the classical Hotel
anymore
consumer is the Epsilon's imply a
worst-case kind of privacy laws but not
the typical time I'm not sure can use it
to directly yeah but you're just
assuming epsilon is coming from D P I
don't care what our population level I
understand correctly you're you're
saying the issue is that users may not
even have the same ranking of privacy
that as being captured we'll get to that
in a minute
use it so I use it so the user can have
any value from zero to epsilon bar okay
the user could be sitting anywhere the
users X Google and duck taco are fixing
their choices let's start the game there
google inducted or fixing their choices
they're gonna look at all the users so
every time there's an interaction with
the user and over all possible users
they have to pick the one they pick a
value at the end of the game as to where
they will offer services but there's a
heterogeneity in the users and that's
sort of captured by a random variable
that models how users are distributed me
under most mechanisms for preserving
privacy and most notions of privacy that
I can imagine different individuals
might experience different privacy harms
and maybe it was giving a worst case
forever use and that's the same items
the terms that go into the utility
function still match up with the
experienced harm - I can take yes is
that okay it's just a mortal assumption
to keep it simple
you're right I mean I it will be idea of
Google so the number epsilon we
understand it as a way to in the process
is a way to bound the user actually
experiences okay I'm just gonna zoom it
like oh you like any single perfect it's
been defined rate generally here like
any single parameter I would I think
also can limit is like the payment since
it says tries to capture a maximal kind
of harm i I'm not work for definitions
that they love like that so I guess any
kind of linearization of like this zero
the epsilon bar scale says that like
assuming that it so in particularly for
the same mechanisms sp1 and SB to Kobe
may Ray sp2 is better unlike in terms of
you know disclosure he may prefer SB to
test b1 I may prefer sp1 to sp2 right so
if I understand correctly what you're
saying is that the ranking of the
different
is going to be the same for all users
the what how much value they assign to
like the code cause but like the there's
like one number you know the fact that
epsilon 2 is epsilon is bigger than
epsilon 1 from my point of view implies
that it does also the same that is
correct
those absolute values of epsilon 1 and
epsilon 2 yes that is correct
I might serve me may not care that
epsilon 2 is too large because I might
be here but yes that is correct
yeah so that sounds great I'm on board
with that I'm just uh wondering remind
me or clarified the sort of what the
users preference or if they're tight so
I understand that service providers are
on the epsilon line does the user have a
they have a type that's on this line
that user has a distribution on this
line so you could be users could be
uniformly distributed it could be
Gaussian distributed on catered Gaussian
whatever you but yes my realization I'm
coming to it oh it's okay
so so heterogeneous so I'm actually
going to model it with a random beer so
there's a CDFI section okay so in this
case obviously a set of map price to QoS
and then I also mention this this
mismatch is no longer symmetric so if a
user was sitting here you know because
it actually gets it when I when I put
down the utility function you'll sort of
see this but one thing I want to point
out is there always exist a point on
this line where I what you'd call it in
the first section well you know the
value from both both espy's are the same
for any user okay so I explicitly
written something here and we'll come to
that in a minute so consumer so the
consumers total utility is a sum of two
parts one that comes from QoS and the
other that comes from the privacy
violation so I'm going to map the
privacy violation to AQS quantity just
by multiplying it by this factor T right
so so this is the actual value that
service provider I provides me in terms
of a privacy guarantee this is the
normalized position on the zero one line
of my choice - the the privacy guarantee
that's been given right so that's sort
of the gain or the loss I have relative
to my preference for this particular
service provider and T is my factor that
goes from privacy to secures it's how
much this consumer values privacy in QoS
units okay way of mapping it and it's
all linear it's classic pretending it's
linear okay all right so if you look at
this obviously for this consumer selling
here SP one is giving it positive
utility whereas SP two is giving it
negative
so here's the attorney the net utility
of the consumer is going to be the
Cure's plus this quantity already told
you that
so okay he's a standard notation of
saying for my strategy this is the
strategy of the other service bar
there's two of them the way you can you
have a game as really because the profit
of every service provider depends on the
choices made by the other through the
number of users that pick this one of
that so the profit per user times the
total number of users a fractional users
is going to be the sorry the revenue
minus cost times the fraction is the
profit for each service part okay all
right so there are two assumptions here
we're gonna assume that these service
providers are rational in the sense
they're not going to offer non-negative
and the problems this is a parametric
game so the only place where these
parameters make sense only place where
the game makes sense is where these
parameters actually allow you to ensure
the market is completely covered so so
what that means is that that means it's
possible that nobody provides services
below a certain MC so we're not going to
zoom the market will be completely
covered by the two service providers so
one service provider will be sitting
somewhere here and the other will be
sitting somewhere it won't be these non
convex regions Union or there will be a
service prior to providing any value of
privacy over the serene normalize region
yes they would not abandon any region
there's just I mean it is possible to
have a solution where they both abandon
or certain region is all I'm saying
we're not gonna do that
not a region of what they picked the
region of users who just all right right
they use yes correct so so so think
about this this is really the range of
users preferences right so it's possible
that they both abandon this the share of
the users to not provide them any
service it's possible to do that
we're not doing that for exemptions that
we're not doing they aren't picking a
reach that's all I'm trying to say in a
long long wait maybe I shouldn't have
even brought that up but yes but it's
important to bring it up in the
following way that because there are so
many parameters these parameters will
only allow you there only there's only
some parameter ranges for which you can
get solutions that's all it's saying and
that will become clear and I think just
to make sure I understand what you're
saying that um it could be that like I'm
a person where both of these people are
providing me like negative utility and I
stay home and does this assumption
saying there is no such person like
everyone would rather go to at least one
of these providers is that the same as
saying the market is covered yes that is
the same as yes that is him saying that
pretty little bit more nuanced than that
maybe will become clear when I work out
some more of the mat for a concrete cost
and revenue function okay so let's just
see how the game is played so so the way
you play this actually you serve this
game is as a sequential game and so the
so so each service provider sort of
advertises its QoS and its risk every
consumer picks the the service provider
that maximize it for them and then the
rewards of the service each service
provider Computers rewards and so the
reward is of every service provider is
really its profit and then the rewards
of the consumer is the best utility it
gets from the two servers so because
there's this interaction through the
consumer between the two service
providers you can sort of break this up
into what's called a sequential okay so
so in the first stage the service
providers are sort of announced this is
the privacy
we're gonna go and then based on that
privacy risk so keep in mind this he
sort of really one independent parameter
so based on the private service they
come up with a cures that x 2 and but
then and this in the last stage of the
game the consumer picks the service
pearl for these particular values so
when you do these three stage games or
any sequential game
there's this notion of this a
well-defined solution and that's this
sub game perfect Nash equilibrium and
it's sort of exactly what it means in
each sub game of the sequential game
there's a Nash equilibrium which means a
point at which neither player service
provider diverse from this choice okay
and then the actual equilibrium so so
it's a solution that Ganci is the
natural cover for each sub game and one
way of calculating this is to actually
use what's called backward induction so
you'd start for a fixed value of these
two you'd start for the consumers choice
then you'd go back and then use the
consumers choice to determine for a
fixed value of this what the cure says
and then you go back and solve this so
here's something that is useful to know
that we can prove that is that there's
really no sub game perfect Nash
equilibrium at which both users offer
the same
what this means is that if they were
both to offer the same privacy risk one
user one SP can always do better form by
moving me from that that means they can
get a better profits by actually
offering either a smaller or larger okay
so the only way I can solve this is to
assume some more models on the cost and
the revenue so here's what we did we
start with something very simple we took
a linear model on the cost in the
revenue so and I think I sort of assume
this right I assume that cost is going
to be a sum of the cost that comes some
key words and a sum of a cost that comes
from providing a privacy guard and I'm
sort of writing that out so for a given
Q is this some scaling factor that
converts it to say dollars and for a
given privacy risk that a service
provider offers there's a mapping to
coerce and then there's a mapping to
cost and for revenue since I get revenue
from using your private data I can map
that into some revenue scale factor and
then this part is this part is where
maybe there's a loose correlation with
what I would call barrier to entry
say for example Google had an ability to
make revenue in many other ways without
using all your data directly that is a
different shader for the two so this is
not coming from the private data it's
sort of a non private gain that revenue
that each service
yeah yes but but so the way to look at
this revenue is to say that this is the
revenue they would make just by being
able to perhaps get a lot of people to
use the platform but but not from using
that data yeah it's a little hard for me
to quantify but the only thing I wanted
to say is that is there a differentiator
between them that's independent of users
data so they just put a number in it
right so for every consumer that's
you've already seen this right so
broadly there's really there's a lot of
parameters here but to look at this
epsilon goes from 0 to epsilon bar okay
revenue depends on a non private revenue
that they can generate and from the
privacy what's the revenue and I'm
obviously assuming that these ours and
C's are the same for each service
provider which is also over simplistic
model but we start them right and then
there's an operation cost for each
service provider which is also assumed
to be the same playing playing field and
those are these coming the operation
cost of providing your sound cures and
an operation costs are giving you a
certain privacy guarantee and the last
part is how much does a consumer value
privacy and that comes from how much do
I map privacy a privacy choice to Cure's
so there are all these parameters they
sort of come into play in some fashion
so we're going to assume a uniform
distribution over the heterogeneity of
consumers choices in in privacy and then
you can so the CDF just becomes directly
just a normal I salon i over epsilon but
epsilon 1 epsilon 2 is the choice that
each one of these service providers
giving over epsilon back all right so
there's all these quantities here so I
just want to quickly go to a sort of
some cute results so for this particular
model of revenue and cost what we can
say is there actually exists a sub
perfect Nash equilibria okay and here's
what I meant so the model parameters
have to facilitate a competitive market
meaning the model parameters cover the
entire range of possibilities so the
entire all consumers can have a choice
that's the assumption we're making under
the conditions that all consumers can
have a choice and there exist model
parameters that facilitate that there
exist a sub-game perfect now she could
yes there's an assumption then the
skadootch and so this is not too
important here's what what's at
equilibrium what are the strategies so
here's dr. go and here's google and from
the math and from this model it sort of
turns out that they said about
three-quarters of your entire range of
privacy values apart as you mM seven
bars is finite okay and so and then the
equilibrium curves choices is obviously
dr. go gives you lower Q s and then
assign it's related in the following
manner but here are some of the
interesting observations right if you
look at this piece these peas where the
rep was the revenue that each service
provider could make that's independent
of using your privateer so Google had a
way to make more revenue than say doctor
go independent of consumers data then
Google has a huge advantage can offer
can actually get away by offering
violating your privacy way more because
it can actually make more oh no see that
it'll make more profit you can sit quite
far apart if they have a non private
differentiator all right so there's lots
of parameters but here's the sort of
simple way to think about it there's a
revenue independent of consumers private
there there's a consumers valuation and
then there's this whole heterogeneity
business right and as all these
operation cost so here's what happens
these are all the consumers that
actually pick this service provider in
fact consumers who have a
evaluation of privacy that's a larger
don't go with this they actually go with
with with the one that violates their
privacy more simply because the curious
turns out to be better and these things
depend on the parameters but that's how
the space Adam you are actually uh
making faces the x-axis is the
normalized valuation of privacy so this
is how the normalized valuation of
privacy gets broken up between the two
service providers where service provider
one us huh yeah so a small epsilon is
very private but you said lower
valuation sorry yes x-axis is Epsilon
normalized to one Epsilon no epsilon can
be any range from zero to epsilon bar
for this entire talk we could just set
epsilon bar to be one and it would all
make sense okay okay so now it now it's
saying people whose relative value of
privacy took us like who value privacy
more relevant us there at the bottom
there on the left end only because we
made an assumption that the the whole
field will be covered so but the
takeaways here are the following really
there's this really three little
takeaways the the service brother that
has a large non-private revenue has a
larger market
so that's one takeaway the other
takeaway is that the competition softens
if there's a very large so this is where
the epsilon bar matters so if you want
to put that away for a moment the
competition softens if consumers value
privacy a lot so that T that takes you
from safe privacy to a same unit as QoS
if that T is very large this competition
is going to suffer so that's not
surprising right and if it's very
expensive for either service provider to
provide you very high QoS guarantees
then the competition's offenses right so
in fact so if meaning you get closer and
closer to 1/2 they will have both will
have a similar share of the market if
consumers get start valuing privacy a
lot that actually pushes their private
option to be worth no if so so so you so
there are multiple parameters keeping
some fixed sure completely understood
your question what I'm saying is that
you're right if consumers value privacy
a lot so doctor go has a better market
ship keeping all other things cost less
privacy preserving the product as a
result the more people like privacy the
worse the products go yeah yes yes or
the more the cost of providing good good
searches the less and the similar thing
happens here as well if a cost of giving
you a very high quality search goes up
the market softens as run competitions
officer which is equivalent to saying
yeah they give you very similar privacy
guarantees there's no distinction
between there was some other parameter
lambda which was not T lambda was like
the quality of service to privacy
for the producer yes and that comes in
it should come in here but them maybe
just one last point about this is that
so there's a certain amount of profit
each one of these make yes I'm going to
be done thank you so much all right you
know what quickly going into some
results it's the fair thing to do over
parameterize this or you took a big
range of epsilon this so here's the
thing right
only this range of epsilon bar which is
your maximum rest mattered to in this
particular setting where we took these
values for the parameters to have a
feasible market meaning where every
consumer could who has a certain privacy
choice can be can have a particular
service project okay to cover the market
and so what you're seeing here is really
the market share as a function if people
get more and more tolerant they have a
bigger privacy risk the market share for
obviously service provider one goes
process this a little bit for my own
self for a moment there's a lot of
parameters here I'm losing it very
quickly
I I can't answer your lambda question
but I'm gonna answer the T question T is
how much you value right so as it as T
increases service provider one gets a
larger market share that's basically all
this is singing so we're gonna stop it
there there's a lot more plot but the
the big idea here is that big or small
whatever the idea is is to ask if you
could differentiate two service
providers in a certain manner through
privacy and QoS but there's no price
involved and modify the Hotelling model
how can you look at competition and the
idea that only two takeaways I would ask
you today is if people consumers value
privacy a lot it softens competition and
it is possible to be profitable if you
have a differentiated
[Applause]